atelier vérif vélo ce samedi matin place
du marché
la liste agir avec vous pour villepreux
conduite par valérie ben proposé aux
habitants de faire vérifier l'état des
roues des freins de leurs deux roues
nous ce qu'on voulait démontrer c'est
que avec peu de matériel
avec peu de moyens on peut arriver à
sensibiliser les gens nous agissons
la liste se veut citoyenne ouverte
plurielle et participative
on est tous salariés on est engagé
effectivement chacun d'un point de vue
associatif et à notre niveau et il ya un
engagement sincère et réel l'occasion
pour l'équipe d'évoquer avec les
habitants les points forts de leur
programme la démocratie participative le
développement de la culture ou encore le
gel du projet central park
la liste s'oppose à la multiplication
des programmes d'immobilier à villepreux
nous allons passer de 10000 à treize
mille habitants et nous trouvons que
c'est largement assez à l'échelle de
notre ville maintenant il s'agit
d'intégrer toutes ces populations de
retrouver en fête donc cette création
quartier a mobilisé beaucoup de
ressources financières et maintenant il
s'agit de se recréer en fait quand entre
guillemets un bas de laine pour pouvoir
améliorer la qualité de vie de tous les
villes provient dans tous les quartiers
de lune pseudo concertation mais on nous
en posant un nombre de logements et nous
c'est pas comme ça du tout qu'on veut
fonctionner nous c'est vraiment dans le
participatif avant le premier tour
valérie ben donne rendez-vous une
dernière fois aux habitons le vendredi
13 mars à 20h30 à l'école du val joyeux